why the [ __ ] was my cup so little you
know that's right you got a bigger cup
you got a bigger cup this is what i got
and i got a fancy ass cube dog
this is like one of the cups that they
eat the [ __ ] softball egg out of
the [ __ ] softball ostrich egg this is
one of them [ __ ] egg cups like
this
[Music]
we're dropping the first two episodes of
the real ones and today we feature a
city that is right in the center of my
heart city of baltimore this episode
features my friend d watkins he is an
unbelievably talented writer he's a
professor at the university of baltimore
and he's the editor at large for
salon.com
he grew up in the heart of baltimore
right in its infamous east side he was
in the drug game he was on the streets
and he's made it his life's work to
examine his experience talk about his
come up talk about his life including
his interactions with the police i first
got into contact with dee the second i
finished reading his unbelievable
article baltimore's most hated cop in me
i read that article and i had to reach
out since then we've worked together on
an upcoming tv mini-series set in
baltimore you know i was talking on the
way up here when i was driving over and
like my [ __ ] with you is is is crazy man
because i read that salon piece that you
wrote
uh most hated cop you know and that [ __ ]
just blew my mind you know and i and and
you know i reach out to you and i told
you how much i loved it and you know
then everything kind of came full circle
you told me you were working on this
show then we ended up working on this
show together like a year later whatever
yeah no i yo i saw you playing that but
i couldn't slide david like i couldn't
slide david
listen man that like so a hundred
percent everything happened like like i
hate that well everything [ __ ]
happened like that that's some like no
but it's some real real [ __ ] dude it's
like as much as you want to fight that
[ __ ] like everything does happen for a
reason but you know i read that and i
had never been excited by an article
like i've been excited by that and then
i took a deep dive you know i read the
cook up first and and and i told you man
like you are the most exciting author
like i love your work man i love you as
a writer and i feel like
the piece you know clearly showed you
know authenticity and all the like
[ __ ] words that people use the grit
and that it was like lived in that you
experienced but the thing that kind of
like blew me away
uh
was the empathy if you could just
because i don't know
you know how many of the people who are
going to be watching this like no will
you just kind of like walk me through
like what that what that piece was yeah
like explain it through explain it for
us you know the funny thing about it is
when i wrote the cook up i couldn't
write that piece why i could because i'm
a whole different person when i wrote
the cook up i didn't have the ability to
consider a perspective that was outside
of my own social context i didn't have
it it wasn't in me yeah it was an emmy i
can tell you well let me tell you how it
is over here nah how about [ __ ] you yeah
it's right what's my mentality because
that's what the world taught me
i've had some experiences
had some nice dinners i had some [ __ ]
all types of red duck meat and lamb
chops and shrimp buttered down
[ __ ] like some wild [ __ ] so i've been
some places right so i had some
experiences but the essay
the essay that you read and it's crazy
how and we're not gonna get on this
aloof goofy [ __ ] universe like
crystals and [ __ ] stars [ __ ] yeah you
know i got a quartz like we're not we're
not we're not gonna do that but i'm
gonna keep it a beam it was the it was
an art so the new york a guy from the
new york times was like
yo we want something from you on this
right he was like yo i found you he's
like yo i read the b side um back in
whatever whatever that's my first book
and he was like
i know that you can kill something on
the gun trace task force in baltimore
i'm coming to you and i'm like yo bet
let's do something he was like now like
come to new york i want you to come to
new york let's sit down let's spend the
day together so i'm like [ __ ] it let's
do it so i get to new york
and we hanging out and we shooting the
[ __ ]
and
he's like i'm pitching him and he's like
yo give me a date to go to my pitch
meeting tomorrow we gonna make it happen
right so i'm like cool the next day he's
like um
yo there's another guy in baltimore who
has a story coming and it's not like
your story but
he writes for us all the time and the
editor outranks me so we got to take his
story
and he's like um
how about you write something for our
recommendation page right so i was like
damn because this was going to be a 3
000 word story yeah and it was going to
like pay some pretty good money how many
words is it it's like 10 000. yeah but
this is what happened this is this is
like how [ __ ] just works out yeah i love
the new york times i love new york times
magazine i love the readership i love
all of that but
i didn't get the opportunity so my my i
got a a friend in baltimore named will
hilton who writes for new york times all
the time as well
and he was like yo don't you just take
the high line so i'm like okay that's
cool so he sent me that number to the
guy from highline and he was like yo not
only will i pay you more than what they
was going to pay you [ __ ] 3 000 words
you can give me 10. and has was anything
written yet or was just the treatment of
what you were going well i was already
going to court cases
like because i just like to go to court
i just like yo going to court yeah it's
wild fun when you like you're not when
you're waiting
straight up but it's not your future
this is why people like hook movies so
much they're like yo yeah watching this
hood [ __ ] is wild when like
i don't gotta [ __ ] duck the bullets
and [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] thrill yeah so
i mean so i'm in court i'm in court like
like um filming but not filming but
taking notes and um
monitoring things and you know looking
looking in the eyes of people and just
trying to see what was happening and the
opportunity went fr it went from being
like a um
seven thousand dollar gig to like a 25
30 000 gig
because i got denied right so this is
why you don't really get like go crazy
when you don't get what you want because
there's always like some other
there's something else waiting and you
might not know
so will hooked me up with this place
called highline
and highline editor was with it
and he was turned up like he you know we
we spoke on the phone for like
supposed to be we booked out like 45
minutes to speak after like three
minutes he's like [ __ ] you get on the
phone go to work yeah so i'm like yo you
know what i actually don't want to talk
yeah i actually want to go to work yeah
so so i went to work and the essay was
about
how
i met this police officer
at three different phases in my life
first time i met him i was young i was
playing ball i
i thought i had a future playing ball
like
maybe not like not an nba future i knew
i wasn't that good i was wasn't tall
enough i've already been shot like it
was just too many things working against
me but i thought i had like uh
i love playing basketball right i love i
know i was going to do something around
basketball and he came they came on the
court and they made all of us lying on
the ground and
this particular day i didn't feel like
laying on the ground because
i wasn't playing ball
so i had my good clothes on and i wasn't
hustling so why do i got to go through
this
and
he's talking this [ __ ] and i say
something back and he kicks me in my
ribs he kicked the [ __ ] out of me right
like he kicked he kicked the [ __ ] out of
me and um
you know i never forgot him and then the
second time i come across this guys now
i'm not
i'm still down i'm still down i'm from
downhill in east baltimore at this
particular time i'm moving up the hill
and i'm by broadway and diggy land
projects um um someone said housing
projects so now i'm coming at him i'm
meeting him in a different capacity and
he's still talking [ __ ] he's still
running his mouth but now he's he's
patting pockets oh you got the little
300 400 on you there let me get that and
me i'm like yo
you telling me
you take this 300 and whatever's on me
and i don't got to go to central booking
and sit in that cold ass cell that
[ __ ] piece of bologna and that
[ __ ] soft untoasted toast and you
know that powder egg [ __ ] guess what i'm
good
take the 300.
you know i was gonna freak out i was
[ __ ] off anyway i was i was blowing
money anyway take it right
so i met him under that capacity then i
clean my life up and i'm not in the
streets no more i'm a good guy now i'm a
solid citizen i'm trying to find [ __ ]
um a living wage and all that [ __ ] um
what the [ __ ] is joe buttons joe biden
to talk about yeah
i'm trying to [ __ ] find like a living
wage and [ __ ] i'm trying to work and my
young boy
is
taking over the neighborhood on the rap
tip
like and he's taking over the whole east
baltimore movie
and now moose is banging in west
baltimore now moves banging throughout
the city now moose is banging he's doing
his thing
and his cop already locked moose up
multiple times one incident he locked up
moose's mom he said oh you're the mother
boom slam on the car and he locked him
up because moose was rocked him up but
he locked them up because
moose started getting famous on the rack
to his name started ringing bells
and he started shooting videos and when
he shot the video uh i believe it was
for the song posted
he had like some props in the video and
he locked them up saying that you know
these were like real items when there
was no way to prove it and moose is like
yo i'm dropping videos they get a
million hits on youtube so why on the
[ __ ] when i sell a drug it doesn't make
any sense
but herschel
worked really hard to try to end his
career
so
i'm like yo not only did this guy [ __ ]
me over before i ever stepped in the
streets
[ __ ] me over when i was in the streets
and i expect that but then he's [ __ ]
the young boys over who was trying to
like
like help a young fledgling art
community
come together because when you rap
you're paying the engineer you might be
paying the person who'll do this on a
stylist tip you're paying the person you
know to uh to put the cd packages
together and all that like
you're paying like you know the girl
singing on a hook like there's all of
these local artists
working together using pooling their
resources and money
to try to create a movement and you got
this cop who's out here that the city is
not only paying his salary
but they already [ __ ] out a quarter
million dollars in misconduct
settlements so you're not only [ __ ]
the residents but you're [ __ ]
the taxpayers um who are residents as
well so
i wanted to tell that story and i wanted
to just really really really like break
it down because it just gave
me um it gave me an opportunity to show
how small baltimore is this guy grew up
a mile away from me
had a whole different reality and i
thought it was like phenomenal that he
started off as just like
a regular white guy with limited talents
and you know but became a cop and like
him becoming a cop to his family was
like
how a good family would feel when their
kid becomes like
the doctor that cures a rare disease
like oh my god you made it right and
like i started out in the street and
then i ended up being a scholars
professor and then he ended up going to
federal prison and i thought the
parallels was just like some [ __ ] that
you know
one of them situations where the jokes
kind of right themselves
so i kind of like i felt like that was i
felt like that was like the type of
situation that i wanted to create and um
and [ __ ] i mean it worked like you
know i mean i met true but then like yo
we like my divine manager
it's like maybe like 20 people banging
his line down trying to buy that and
like some really really big names but
like the the you stuck out to me because
i'm like yo this is
you know this guy is like he's just a
[ __ ] like he's sterile i ain't know
about the boxing i ain't know about none
of that [ __ ] like i didn't know you from
dc
i was like yo he's just a just a good
person man i i appreciate that man but
like i i'll tell you just through the
art man through what you created
you know i was i you know again man it's
like that's that's what we're looking
for like what you you know like that's
the best thing that art can do
just excites you make you just open up a
whole new window of of a way of looking
at things i think sometimes the best
thing that art can do is it can put a
name it can it could it can locate
something that you've only felt in your
heart but you've never had it really
worked out and the thing that like i'll
say really hit me and i watched the
documentary uh this morning as well and
and you said something in there that
that that reflected it
is you know you had hate for this dude
and and justifiably so like he kicked
you when you were
when you were young but then like the
thesis of the thing and what
what i was so taken with is you were
like if i don't even try to understand
him or why he where he come from or why
he's making the decisions that he did
then why should anybody under try to
understand me because you [ __ ] up as
well that just resonated with me in like
a i i in a very pure way let me let me
say this
a lot of big names hit me up you are you
are a big name too but who you who you
were
in our conversation
just had more weight it just had more
weight and i think that [ __ ] is
important because
if a person has a lot of success
and is like a horrible [ __ ] then
you're never going to kind of get what
you want out of that situation anyway
and i think we really need to think
about that we need to think about that
because we jump you know on oh my god
you know the guy who made it
wants to [ __ ] with you but if that guy's
a [ __ ] then you're kind of not
really gonna get what you want but i'll
say this so i i have a daughter
um she's one years old she'll be two in
january
and
i know
that if
my story ends in baltimore and we stay
in baltimore and she goes through the
schools and she goes through whatever
programs and she does whatever she's
whatever she's into
in her life somebody's gonna stop her
and they're gonna say
yo
your father gave books to my school your
father visited my school your father was
the person who helped my whatever get
started their writing career he got them
an agent he put money in their pocket he
he we was on the air mattress he brought
us to bed with the box spring and the
[ __ ] prosthopedic all that [ __ ] like
yo he's that [ __ ] like yo i love him
like your father changed my whole [ __ ]
and then i know that somebody's gonna be
like yo your father
[ __ ] brought the violence from down
the hill to the projects these gun plays
here because of what him and his friends
did they [ __ ] the neighborhood up they
did terrible [ __ ] he doesn't deserve
anything
and
god willing if i'm around i'm gonna have
to explain that to her i'm gonna have to
tell her like yo the stuff that i do
a lot of it is a result of someone not
just the pain i went through but the
pain i caused and then there's a healing
process that i'm gonna be going through
for the rest of my [ __ ] life so
get off your high horse and get off your
oh my god he's a black literary [ __ ]
that [ __ ] because you have to i have to
say
that
i'm not perfect i've been a bad person
i've done some horrible things and i've
tried my best to make amends for that
and i know i'm going to be working on
that [ __ ] for the rest of my life some
[ __ ] that i did as a teenager in my
early 20s is some [ __ ] i'm going to be
trying to fix when i'm [ __ ] 60 70 80
years old
and you have to understand that so
yeah i think this guy has been a bad
person i think this guy never really
understood the error of his ways but i
also understand that
nobody especially me has the right or
the power to throw this person away
because we don't solve the [ __ ]
problem by saying oh my god this is the
bad group this is the good group this
group we don't solve problems like that
we solve problems by saying
oh okay
he's a victim of a certain culture
just like me
let's understand the culture that he
comes from
and let's try to let him know
what works and what doesn't work yeah
and then we start there
when you say you uh a victim of culture
can you tell me about that like kind of
walk me through uh a victim of culture
yeah you know i grew up um in the murder
unit um i i grew up in
you know gun play was gun play was
it was normal and everybody hustled and
you know like the way selling drugs and
all that [ __ ] look on tv
is it doesn't really mirror reality in a
way
of the drug deal is not always the young
fly dude with the [ __ ] it's not the
young fly black dude who's like
innovative and like the smartest guy in
his class [ __ ] jamal with the highest
test score like it's not it's not always
the case
you know and it's not and he's not
always going to meet the colombian
looking guy with the linen pants [ __ ]
drink champagne at [ __ ] two o'clock
on a tuesday like that's not always the
case sometimes the drunk dealer is the
fedex guy who needs to make an extra 250
a week to be able to pay his [ __ ]
sprint bill and child support sometimes
the drug dealer is the grandma who has
the grandson and she can't [ __ ] keep
him from out the streets so she
organizes it and she distributes it
through the frozen cups just to make
sure her knucklehead grandson stays out
of prison it is very diverse it is a
serious problem addiction plagues this
country and any all types of people
suffer from that [ __ ] and i grew up in a
reality where yo okay yeah so you know
like like cops used to say um
this is a um
this is a drug
free zone so you got to stay out of this
right and we would be in a school like
dog
this is where we live like you put the
sign in front of my door like so how in
the [ __ ] can i not do that yeah and um
and it's it's a normalized thing um
people lose hope
you know and when i say lose hope i
don't mean lose hope for success
or lose hope to make money but they lose
hope in regards to like some of the
traditional career paths that i
presented the young children because the
people who make money are right in front
of you and they're hustling that's right
so let's just say it's like oh and this
is why i we can get into this but this
is why like if i visit a school like in
baltimore i visit the schools in
baltimore i might visit like 10 15 times
in a year because the person
who's in the street they're around every
day
the influence that's not good or the
influence that's trying to you know
pushing the wrong thing they got perfect
attendance straight up so if you're
trying to push something different then
you got to make sure you're pulling up
more than just it's more than a day of
service but the way i came up
is um
selling drugs
almost felt illegal or like normal it
didn't feel like a bad thing so like
yeah we're gonna move this way we're
gonna try not to get caught by the cops
but
it's not that we're scared of jail we're
not scared of prison like yo [ __ ] that
[ __ ] like yo
it's part of it right it's not like oh
my god you know the system is part of it
like it's it's part of it it's part of
the game it's it's part of it no mind
you you got your you know you got your
people like you know oh my god i can't
do it you know john john sold it like
you got
like you got you got those guys but
where i'm from
it was always talked about and presented
as like a normal a normal thing it was
like a normal thing so
um when i decided to hustle
like i knew how to cook crack i knew how
to cut her when i knew how to like i
knew not to touch fitting all because i
don't know how to cut fat enough i don't
know how to cuff it no so i would never
touch fitna i would never be like yo we
gotta get defense i would never do that
because i know that yo i would [ __ ]
kill 250 people like also i would never
i would never do that [ __ ] like but i
already knew these things like i saw
these things i saw these things like you
know you're in the house watching the
smurfs and then you know big brother or
big homie or whatever is in the kitchen
bagging up and it's like yo go you know
go get some ice cubes so we can throw
the ice in it whatever like we you know
whatever and it's like a normal thing
the police are out there and i was just
talking with with them one thing like
i'm really just interested in it and i
thought like you know your essay really
hit upon was just like kind of the
currency of violence and like the
currency like what that does for you
what it does for the police force what
it does for you if you're on the street
it's one part that was it was a part
that was cut off the essay but i put it
in the book so the guy who we run down
on right squeaky he's clarence in the
book
is was my dad he's my dad's friend so i
knew him since i was a small child so it
wasn't like you know like can you just
name one of your dad's good friends
uh peter imagine [ __ ] taking the gun
handle and smacking peter's front teeth
right you're like god damn like yo not
peter you know what i mean peter [ __ ]
brother eggnog like
so
so
when i was a little kid we had they had
this scam where
me and my dad would go to the sneaker
store right yeah this is when air force
ones first came out they [ __ ] first
came out and people didn't know nike
like that and this is like and it's like
yo they got [ __ ] air technology
inside the show that make you feel like
you like walking on air and [ __ ] made by
some astrophysicist people right like yo
this [ __ ] is like wow and baltimore was
like the spot that had like the nike
color of the month so like it was kind
of like the beginning of the multiple
colorway sneaker culture yeah and
clarence used to say yo come in the
store
wear some [ __ ] up shoes take the
[ __ ] up shoes off put them in a box
you take the new shoes wear them out i'm
going to put the [ __ ] up shoes back in
the stock room you don't go to the
register you put the money in my pocket
we good
so that was my god like he kept me
right like i used to find [ __ ] up
shoes to go so that was my guy so you
know whatever happened in his life you
know the sneaker shouldn't work out for
obvious reasons so he's on the block and
he's on the block and now i caught up in
age so now i'm on a block around the
same time he's on the block
and
we have this conflict
and
you know i'm gonna say nick you know
it's gary but i'm gonna say nick because
of you know to be in line with the piece
i
i changed that name for a reason he has
a son you know what i'm saying and his
son is
his son is dealing with the consequences
of his dad's decisions and i think about
that as a parent too but
nick um
i'm telling nick like yo we can't
[ __ ] like no we can work this is my
dog like and he's like
nah he really not though
not no more
you're not training [ __ ] up pumas for
brand new nikes now
now this is like this is a real problem
and it's nothing to talk about and the
crazy thing about it is is me and is
nick me and nick the balance was so
perfect because i'm not what you would
call emotional but i think a lot and
he's really emotional but he's just all
action so if i'm gonna have like a
10-page plan
he has like a two-second solution
and
you need that because without without
him
and this is like you know even more sad
but
without him i would have been dead a
long time ago like he's dead now rest in
peace but without him i would have been
dead because people knew that like you
know you take a hail from my head he's
going to take your head off your
shoulders and that was that's what it
was and i knew that what will get you
killed is the one who'll keep you alive
man
so dress code came home who's dressy but
dressy was dress cold too i mean i
changed it but i didn't because he was
both and when he came home um
it was my turn and
i had to i had to put hands on him
because we we in the field every day
yeah so i know that he ain't gonna touch
me he ain't gonna touch me he's gonna
touch me because he's scared of you
but what do you think of me
and that becomes a brand new
conversation so i gotta make sure you
know i'm about all of this stuff you
about even though i do this other stuff
that's right i'm about with you about or
you can work me out the situation and it
becomes that kind of reality
and it becomes that recounted reality
and you know and you you fight and you
you bleed and you get your hands dirty
you you know sometimes you get your ass
whipped sometimes you whip ass and
you know it's it's um you know sometimes
you need to you need you need that too
you know like you think it it's a
complete mirror like a complete exact
mirror the way that it also works for a
lot of these guys on the on the police
i think that a lot of these guys
doesn't mean they're not tough doesn't
mean they can't fight they can fight
they can do all of these things
but
it doesn't really come out it doesn't
come out of them at 12 years old doesn't
come out of them in the youth jail
doesn't come out of them
than first year high school it comes out
of them when they get that badge and
that gun and i think um sometimes
proving a point becomes a different
thing to them because it's like their
first experience
in being in like a real gang because if
you're in a gang gang then you're not
gonna get the job
so if you're never in the gang and then
you get with them it's your first time
in a gang and you gotta prove to them
right that you can
that you can stand up and you can do
that and i know that
on a deeper level because guess what we
never talked about this my sister is a
county cop
she was in her early 20s
she had a baby father that like wasn't
really making the bread
that
she thought he should be making to take
care of
their family so she left him
and she her whole family's gangsters and
she [ __ ] with us yeah you know and
she became a cop and she said that when
the bra broke out
you know black woman teamed up with like
mostly men
um and it's the county so it's mostly
white men they looking for her to throw
hands so she had to throw hands
or they don't want to people don't want
to link up with her right and
we have these conversations um because
she got some years on the force now like
to the point where she can almost retire
and
any argument that's gonna be like the
argument that a police officer would
make she's gonna rot with them right
she's gonna ride against me she's gonna
ride against our father she's gonna ride
against our cousins she's gonna ride
with that perspective because she's
deeply interested in that culture right
and
that is just it's it is necessary it is
necessary for her to have that mentality
because even though biologically we are
her family
she's not spending
50 hours a week with us right she's
spending 50 hours a week with them right
so she has to align her thoughts and
beliefs have to align with them and i
respect that and i got i got you know i
i love her daily like that's she's my
heart but
when it comes to that conversation we
don't have them we don't really go deep
into the conversations because we don't
see the world the same way right right
was it one major event was it a series
of events like what gave you to kind of
like
kind of put that kind of life behind you
and and uh to to kind of dive in fully
to be to be an artist
you know how fire would it be if i was
like i watched the punisher that would
be the [ __ ] thank you
i'm looking forward
but like the good she would have been
like i saw you on law and order and i
just saw such truth
it's like and the sexiness yeah yeah
like you know like you [ __ ] hanging
out with lieutenant vincent
no um yo the thing for me
so it was like it was a number of things
um the first is
i came of age
i've came up in the streets in a crack
era the crack was dying down
it wasn't the same as it was even
you know two years after i started three
years after i started it was different
so that's one of the things second thing
is
second thing is i um i started traveling
and i started going to different um
cities and different countries even and
all of a sudden my neighborhood and
everything i believed in and subscribed
to just felt this big wow third thing is
my best friend
my best friend taylor robertson had got
sentenced to 27 years for non-violent
drug crimes he came home he did 16
and um his sentence you know he was able
you know he was able to come home
he did 16 years with the feds
and um you know he he was at the
hollywood museum the other day with like
posing with like the wax figures making
jokes and [ __ ] like you know it's all
new he's like he's home you know like
he's home and [ __ ] but like
you know him getting that time
was and not having him there with me
and then you know gary with nick dying
and like some other people dying and
just the the whole like you know the
snowball effect of all of these
different things was just like yo
do you want to be
the guy that's like on the block and
you're like
30 years old and all your good friends
are like 18 you know like
some al bundy high school reminiscing
[ __ ] you know what i mean like well do
you want to do something different with
your life and
i had um
i also had oh i got shot
and
i wasn't running from when i got shot
but i had to get like a a procedure done
um like a piece of slug that was stuck
in my bone out and when i went to go get
that done
i'm in the hospital
it's just nurse right and um
she was cool she was like she went for
the neighborhood but she seemed like she
was from the neighborhood she was cool
and
i've never ever ever saw a person with
their hair stuck in the book like that
so she would come in my room three
o'clock in the morning and read and she
have a head deep in the book and it's
not like a lot of [ __ ] on the tv it's
like i mean you know it's like mash and
like this show mama's family you heard
of this about like a mom and her family
so like it's [ __ ] like that on the tv
and it's cool but you can't watch it for
like 30 hours and
she will come in with this book and i'm
like yo damn that must be a good book
and she's like yo you would like that
book and i was like nah i don't [ __ ]
with no book and she's like with the
last last time you read a book i was
like oh no i read a book recently so
what you read
i said 48 laws of power she said i mean
they didn't read that [ __ ] i said i know
i did
everybody would tell you they read that
book they never read it right
it's actually not that bad but it's like
what book does she have so she had a
book called the coldest winter ever
and by sister soldier
and we made some jokes about it and
she's like yo you would really like this
book and i'm like yo why would i like
this book she said because it's about
you and your friends i said me and my
friends she said yeah it's about thugs
i said ain't no thug she said
everybody who visits you smell like a
bunch of weed even old people and i was
like duh they got cataracts
and she's like she started laughing and
[ __ ] and then she rolls out she left the
book
so i woke up three o'clock four o'clock
in the morning to pick the book up and
start thumbing through the pages and i'm
like damn i never knew you could write a
book like that yeah
and i never saw her again
and like i went home and i'm like yo
what else sister soldier right so now
i'm reading all of her [ __ ] so i'm like
damn yo when she got interviews oh she
mentioned this ladies or nealy hurston
what's she writing about oh tony
morrison well let me read that james
baldwin oh he was alive around the same
time as the beat nick uh the beat nick
so let me read on the road and naked
lunch and what the [ __ ] is they talking
about oh so who's this guy that was
referenced fedor dostoevsky oh so now
i'm sitting on ashland avenue reading
the [ __ ] idiot
in my homie like yo what is the idiot
about the dude who [ __ ] his life above
with girls just like your dumbass you
know like so
now i'm in like [ __ ] i'm i'm
knee-deep in literature and i've tapped
into some whole other [ __ ] that i've
never even knew i cared about because i
got that one book and um
i was already in the transition in my
life i was in college but i wasn't a
reader i was there and i was like yo i'm
gonna go to school for criminal justice
and i don't even [ __ ] know what to do
with that [ __ ] like but i just didn't
know because i didn't know anybody went
to college so i didn't know what to do
once i got that book i'm like oh no [ __ ]
that i want to write and then um i
started reading like a lot of articles
and i'm like yo a lot of these reporters
are full of [ __ ] like because
they're quoting people in these articles
and i'm like yo
we don't even talk like that like
you didn't nobody said that [ __ ] like
and one thing i've learned in all the
studying and reading is that
the best form of critique
is creation
you don't like it contribute
so
that's when i threw my hat in the ring
and start like trying to publish and
get down with like publications and and
get my stuff out there and um
and it took a while
but when i got it i got like the first
essay i wrote that click um
back in 2014
that's when i first came across dave
david first email hit me up and reached
out it was like i know these voices i
know these people care you got something
david simon i don't like man this ain't
no [ __ ] david simon so i hit back you
david simon [ __ ] you david simon [ __ ]
where you at i'm just going to get some
money yeah what we what what we working
on yeah and we met up and then he sent
me out to go like work with a couple of
different people on some projects but
the projects never really came together
but
i started building that relationship and
um
and yeah you know
tell me a little bit about your process
like i know you like to write a night
and [ __ ] like that but like do you feel
like you're does it flow out of you does
it like is it come like just describe
what it feels like for you so
it normally starts with an idea and then
i always always always ask myself
why i always ask myself why why are you
doing this why
and i see so many y's i see so many y's
but they just have to be organized and
amplified to be able to connect to like
the bigger
the bigger picture is the why for you
does the y for you help you with your
process or does it settle something in
your heart that says okay this is now
this now anoints me with something pure
enough that that that this is worth my
time everything isn't righteous
but
everything that i've been lucky enough
and blessed enough to work on up into
this moment has been necessary [ __ ] you
you know sometimes
because righteous is such a
such a personal it's a personal thing
you're the only one who can answer it
some [ __ ] might be righteous to him but
i might be like yo man i don't
feel like watching the [ __ ] office
you know what i'm saying i [ __ ] with the
office but i [ __ ] with the office but
i'm not it's not righteous so but it but
it is though yeah you know what i'm
saying so it's like
i don't kind of look at it like that but
i i i more so look at it
through the lens of um
things that
i think are meaningful based on the
people who i've been lucky enough to
interact with one of the things you and
i also first connected on it's like
somebody can come at something with
something that [ __ ] has deep [ __ ]
meaning for them man that they really
really care about but then they hand
that over they get marginalized within
the process very fast because there's
people who have been there before people
who know more or people and then it just
becomes something else and fit into a
box of familiarity and i think
familiarity is like a huge huge enemy in
this [ __ ] man like you gotta steer clear
from that like write the [ __ ] truth
write your truth and you gotta eliminate
i think so many of the middlemen i mean
you just you can't have middlemen in
this thing you just can't we can talk
about intentions we can talk about
people that have good hearts we can talk
about people that have that want to do
the right thing
and we can't demonize them for that
however we can still demonize the system
in in the way that they chose
to exercise that action without calling
them bad people or picking them apart
these are the problems that exist is
like [ __ ] that has just been in line
before all of us were born and we're
chasing that and we're trying to solve
it using the same thing that we've been
trying to use for hundreds of years and
this [ __ ] just doesn't really work and
it's not even a response it's not even
their responsibility to understand that
[ __ ] so it's kind of like we can't even
judge them
the way
that
a lot of them are judged because they
don't even have
the experience the skill set or the
insight to really understand 100
but they do have a skill set and insight
that is valuable based on the lives that
they let and that [ __ ] is valuable too
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
even like if you talk about the show
that we just worked on yeah no writer in
the history
of [ __ ] writing
has ever
articulated
the problem with society
politicians
police officer and culture
better than david did in the book the
corner the book the corner
is so [ __ ] nuanced that like
a person with a limited amount of
reading comprehension could pick that
book up and understand why [ __ ]
doesn't
work while the [ __ ] that we do doesn't
work right
it doesn't work how he remains
optimistic after writing that is some
wild [ __ ] right but and so it's some
it's some wild [ __ ] but
it's a perfect example of when we talk
about what that why is and
the why for me and what i see in a lot
of projects a lot of things that i work
on it becomes just just this whole idea
of let's hold a mirror up and let's just
identify what's happening
and let's show why these things play out
the way they play out but let's be
entertaining and let's be fun and let's
let's get into some [ __ ] let's get dirty
but at the same time let's tell some
real let's tell the hard truth what's
the entertaining fun dirty part like why
one of the things that has been really
successful for me
is
getting my books into schools when i
came into it
i'm like
schools and jails
why schools and jails
because the book of it is gonna sell
[ __ ] 60 copies
the school event is going to sell
1500 2 000.
i'm not a new york times best seller
because i got a [ __ ] sweater
and [ __ ] you know what i mean
dress socks and church shots and [ __ ]
new york times bestseller because i
burnt the schools down
right
but the secret to browning the schools
down
is you trick them into learning
so i can dangle the street [ __ ] in front
of your face but i can give you the why
the lessons of where it came from i can
put it in historical context i can tell
you why it doesn't work and i can plant
something in you to let you know why it
won't work for you [ __ ] it because it
hasn't worked for people who were
tougher and smart like people who are
tougher and smarter than me it didn't
work for you but also because you've
been there like you ain't been there you
can't yeah yeah what love so i can
entertain you with the [ __ ] that you're
entertained by right but at the same
time i can give you the why you don't
need to take this route that's right and
this [ __ ] has been proven it's been
proven it's it hasn't worked like it
hasn't changed the world but it changed
a lot of lives which
is changing the world in my opinion yeah
yeah yeah one person being delivered
is like [ __ ] changing the world crazy
you never know what they're gonna you
never know what they're gonna gonna do
you know when when i kind of like
changed and said okay i'm gonna devote
my life to my work and to my family i'm
gonna trim a bunch of the fat off of my
life
i felt like there was also this big
[ __ ] hole in me man like i felt like
i had this like big emptiness especially
behavior-wise because there was always a
pattern of behavior i would always do i
was always this guy to my friends i was
oh i only know but now since i've given
all that [ __ ] up i was on my own and i
didn't know what to fill it with and i
guess like what you talk about like
being delivered and when you first came
out that [ __ ] did you feel like it was
good or did you think it was trash
i didn't i didn't i didn't really know
but i felt right
i didn't know but it felt right it felt
right doing it
i felt like i was a person to tell the
stories that i was telling i felt like
there was nobody better
but it's kind of hard to gauge it
if you don't have and it's crazy because
i would never tell a young artist to
base their their skill set and their
belief on industry validation like
accolades and [ __ ] but that kind of that
[ __ ] pays the bills so it's like
that [ __ ] pays the bills have you had
rejection as a writer oh [ __ ] yeah yo
you hear some crazy wild [ __ ]
i actually keep that [ __ ]
so i have like like like a shoe box full
of rejection letters at home and then i
have like a list with the names of
people that rejected me just so i can
never forget that [ __ ] okay and i know
it's sick and toxic and kind of like i'm
the same way dude but
i just feel like i need to know you know
what i mean and
it took my agent
it took me over a year to get an agent
then it took my agent like another two
or three years to sell my first book
and like it's it's funny because before
she was a literary agent barbara she
actually was a stand-up comedian so the
fact that she can't sell my [ __ ] and
she's also funny yeah it's like makes
the [ __ ] like even more funny but
at the time when i was writing these
books um
nobody was interested
in the got x drug dealer redemption
makes it to johns hopkins university
redemption story that [ __ ] wasn't it
wasn't hitting back then
it's more hidden now
but it wasn't hitting back then we're
judging based on the checking of boxes
more than we're judging based on the
quality of the art that's right and that
[ __ ]
is why a lot of [ __ ] that you probably
came across on television and film is
[ __ ]
it's not about it's not about check it's
not about putting the [ __ ] on
because of who they what they look like
or who they are and it's not about
putting the [ __ ] on so you can
look diverse it's about how do we get to
the best [ __ ] art
i care about the best art that's what i
care about and i'm gonna stand on that
[ __ ] i'm gonna live by that [ __ ] and i'm
gonna die by that [ __ ] and the industry
for a long time has not benefited me
but i still i stand on i'm gonna work
like that's why i said i'll keep going
back to this
your success is obvious but
who you were as a person when i first
talked to you outweigh all that [ __ ]
it's just it don't mean like because all
the other [ __ ] it don't mean nothing
like
you know what i mean like it just don't
mean anything but i'm like yo you get it
so
we can we can [ __ ] rock and roll and
that's the game there's a world culture
going on right now
where
people have a certain access to a
certain type of like knowledge and ideas
and they don't use it to uplift people
they use it to demonize people who don't
quite understand
and that's my biggest problem with that
[ __ ] so if a [ __ ] don't know
you're not saying look i'm woke so let
me explain this [ __ ] to you you're
saying
you don't know what this means you don't
know what that means you don't know this
you don't know that you let's cancel you
and it's like yo
let's enlighten each other let's let's
let's share the knowledge let's show
some love let's let's build a stronger
community let's not
let's not be torn down and then in turn
you know be oppressed and then dream of
being a little oppressor yourself that's
right let's [ __ ] that's right deal
with the old let's let's deal with the
oppression and utilize that [ __ ] to
uplift [ __ ] so that we can be
an army and a family in a unit and it's
just not happening it's being it's a
competition to like who has access to
the most [ __ ] like you know
that [ __ ] can be like i don't know man i
think all right but racism why the [ __ ]
was my cup so little you know you got a
bigger cup you got a bigger cup this is
like i got and i got a fancy ass cube
dog
this is like one of the cups that they
eat the [ __ ] softball egg out of the
[ __ ] softball ostrich egg this is one
of them [ __ ] egg cups like he come
here with this little [ __ ]
hanging on blunt
yeah
right now dude
should mark we should [ __ ] march we
should [ __ ] like i should organize a
march around this little ass cup
[Laughter]
that's a crazy [ __ ] though because i
think that stuff man i don't know man i
i just uh i think that [ __ ] can be
really dangerous too man [ __ ]
speaking for people you you you know
it's like um especially when you don't
talk to the people you're speaking for
that's what i'm saying you don't talk to
him that's right how do you know what
the [ __ ] they want but what do you know
what the [ __ ] they want right yo a dude
who i respect i ain't gonna say his name
i respect this dude
i respect this dude and we was in
[ __ ] we was in the uk
we was hanging out with the dude who i
told you about who was who stole a piece
of my writing we went to i went to
london one of one of his events early on
and [ __ ] right
and we hanging out with this dude i
respect big name poland and [ __ ]
and we sit in the green room they about
to go on stage right and this dude was
like
he's a black dude he was like
as a you know we don't we don't want
reparations we want free education
and i look like
[ __ ]
i don't want free education i want a
[ __ ] check like what can [ __ ]
make you think you can tell me what i
want yeah we don't just want money we
want free school oh yeah i'm gonna get
free classes of philosophy 102 to talk
about date carton [ __ ] i want to [ __ ]
talk about descartes yeah i was
i was some
[ __ ] gucci [ __ ] like
[ __ ] is you talking about like i want
some drip like
i don't want that but how do you feel so
comfortable saying that
with your chest poked out and your chin
up
what if i went to college for free
already
i have free college so if i have free
college i don't get to check yeah yeah
yeah yeah i've i've enjoyed that yeah i
want the bread dog so like
how can you say that yeah with a
straight face and they're gonna listen
to you more than less than me because
you're world famous right up in there
right up in there you know what i'm
saying it's it it's dangerous [ __ ] when
you
you know i found that i mean even like
when we get when we're talking about
that police thing i mean what's what
what what was your take on that on that
whole movement on the defund movement
and all that
you know like saying
you know obviously my biggest connection
you know my biggest connection now is in
shreveport
and i look at what's going on in that
city and i look at all the violence
and
you know man it's like that [ __ ] has uh
that [ __ ] has caused real problems down
there man yo unpopular opinion
i'll tell you some [ __ ] that you might
not never hear in this era
which you might never hear anybody say
i'm actually unqualified to speak on
that [ __ ]
you know i don't have the qualifications
to speak on it because i can say defund
police all day but i have guns
i [ __ ] like my wife and my daughter
they're in the gated community
like
if you disrespect my wife or my daughter
i will find you i'm on your ass i can
say that
everybody doesn't have that
there's like you can go to like you know
i got family all through baltimore city
and
some of the worst neighborhoods in the
country and as people in my family who
would be like yo
i i called the police to clear the
corner i didn't want the people selling
drugs on my corner on in front of my
house
and might have demonized them because if
something happens i know i'm not going
to be the one to pull up and be like hey
guys 10-4
34-62-7 you need to clear the corner
like i know i'm not going to be that guy
yeah and
the conversation is way more complex
than people have made it on the internet
so just because i don't [ __ ] with police
i don't have to call him i don't have to
deal with them
unless i need an insurance report
doesn't mean that another person hasn't
had an experience where they felt like
they were helped by them
but so i would never get on a public
platform and take a hard stance because
i'm not now if i if you were asking me
about reform and what that looks like i
do think we need a unit of
um unarmed
officers
to
handle
disputes or insurance claims or
non-violent conflicts or traffic stops i
think the key in maintaining the order
could potentially be
disarming a large segment or
or disarming a large segment and sending
them off to get some type of training to
be able to have like the social worker
type of skills to deal with conflict and
but that would be secondary the primary
thing
to do would be
um having
it be a requirement to live in a city
if you're going to police in that city
no more living in pennsylvania no more
living in all that [ __ ] [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] living but living in nate you don't
got to live in a neighborhood where you
work but live in a neighborhood that
mirrors
the neighborhood you work in so you can
get a clear understanding of the people
then we can start having real
conversations then we can start dealing
with conflict in a way that is um
that would be non-violent what do you
see like five years from now like what
do you want man
10 tv shows on
running at the same time straight up
why tv is t why why do you feel like tv
is your medium
because
i don't know if i have the skill set
to tell a story
at 120 minutes
because there's always so much more
all of my favorite books
everything that i read everything
that i'm into
always
goes into perspective the perspective of
different people you take a film
that i really i really enjoy like king
richard
but you want to go home with some of the
trainers you want to go home with some
of the other kids you want to go home
with different you want to go home with
different people you want to see what
other little tennis athletes live like
in comparison to the williams sisters
then you get like a bigger picture of
how effective powerful that [ __ ]
story was beautiful and you can do that
[ __ ] in three hours
it's a little more difficult to do it
you know well also it's like life man
like the thing that's so dope about tv
when it really [ __ ] works and i've
really only had this experience like
once
but
it's there's a fluid relationship
between the show and the writer the
people that are making the show with the
words and the people that are making the
shows with the acting and the and the
and the crew
they're working off of each other so the
writers can watch the show they can see
what you're doing they can say hey man i
see which way you're going i'm going to
write for that i see what you're doing
i'm going to write for that it can be
continual it can be it can continue to
be inspirational rather than i'm going
to shoot something i'm going to finish
it and it kind of is what it is i mean i
know i can write a film like i've
written like i've written i've they've
never been made but like i've written
that [ __ ] before
and
the the medium of television is just
it's just it fits me so and i'm talking
about like
we can do some [ __ ] that's gonna run for
five like you know five seasons or we
can do like mini series that's gonna be
like 10 episodes or i mean even i was
kind of i kind of i wanted we on the
city to be 10. i thought we could have
did 10.
i thought we could have so much more i
see that that documentary i see the
pseudo doc your dog it's like dude
there's so i mean and that was the thing
like for me it was so
that part of the process was so painful
because man like i dug in man like i
seen so like this city is like my heart
now dude like i love this there are so
many people i love and like i'm like i'm
hearing this [ __ ] like yo this scene and
i'm constantly pitching scenes i'm
constantly like yo what about yeah it's
so big man we didn't go home with shop
shire bro that's he so sharp shire was
gondo's homeboy he's in federal prison
right now i'll be talking to him yeah
i'll be talking to him he's like the
main like the main he's the main drug
dealer yeah that kind of sparked this
whole [ __ ] off yeah and we didn't go
home with shopshia we didn't go home
with gondo yeah we didn't go home with
[ __ ] moose yeah story got national
[ __ ] attention we didn't go home with
him and we got into some fights is there
ever any talk about that did you guys
ever
my situation was tricky because
i'm i'm i'm a student of david and i'm a
student of george so
my perspective i definitely felt like it
was super value i felt super appreciated
and super valued but i also understood
my role and my role was the was the
listen and learn that was my role my
role so i didn't even know i was gonna
get an episode coming in coming in
i was like supposed to just be in the
room taking notes and just listening and
just providing like facts and like
things based on my research and stuff
like that from my understanding i didn't
know so when david was like giving out
the episodes and george is giving out
episodes i didn't know they was gonna be
like oh yeah you got three by yourself
like i didn't know that was coming so i
was ready for it but i didn't know so
i do think the elements that they chose
to include were extremely important
but i'm also greedy and i'm greedy in a
way that
i wanted 10 i wanted 10 i wanted 10
hours over 6.
and and
as a student
i also need to learn
how to deal with a network how to talk
to a network about that how to explain
that what that means and what that looks
like yo i think like
from what i saw
i think y'all killed that [ __ ] like i
was at all just watching everybody work
and it energized me to be able to say
well how can you get in a position
where you can create something that that
duplicates this feeling
but but and all i don't get in the
position i was in
if i don't respect the game and there's
so many people that don't respect the
game it's like i got into an argument
with a guy the other day because they
were talking about um
hbo wanted this book but they didn't
want the other book and it's that in the
third and
the person who said it i didn't press
down on them i pressed down on the
person who know that's a [ __ ] lie
and let that lie linger
why are you letting this lie linger and
you know
that you sold the rights to your [ __ ] to
somebody else
why do you ain't say that well you can
say that
because he was gonna buy both and he was
gonna give you guys positions to be able
to be storytellers and you you took
yourselves out of that comment is that
right that's crazy that's at 2 000 wow
wow because i was there yeah i was there
in this city as far as that show is
concerned do you feel like there's like
two like almost two political camps
there's like a camp that's with we own
the city and there's one with i got a
monster like do you feel like absolutely
and like how do you describe those two
camps
i think so and this is like this is
it makes me upset because
i have like a lot of people i respect
and got love for across the board
and
i think that justin has
an extremely important perspective
that needs
to be in existence because
when the case was going on
nine out of ten [ __ ] who was
getting that information
was trusting the information they got
from justin
and you and you're not br you're not
you're not even
having a conversation without the work
that he's put out in the world like him
don't like him whatever you're saying
just in the baltimore sign like him the
bottom of baltimore
[ __ ] trusted him on this
talking
2021 going back to when i was born the
baltimore sun has been baltimore's
newspaper
it just is it's where david's simon
comes from right that's where simon
comes from justin fitton
is the crime reporter
and the information you are getting and
that you are tweeting about and articles
you are sharing and the person who you
are referencing
is fitting in his reporting
i have a close relationship with baynard
woods who wrote a
and like you know like i know i'm cool
with brandon seidenberg too but man
bayonets are actually friends
and baynard is an excellent writer
excellent he's an excellent researcher
he's [ __ ] like he's the best at what
he does like he he's taking my [ __ ] and
picked it apart and like gave me
versions to help me become better i got
love for him so if it's going to come
down to who i'm going to work with like
i finn is a great guy we're cool but
boehner is my actual that's my dog so
if we're gonna have a real conversation
we're not like and david knows baynard's
work so david was like yo i was gonna
get i was gonna buy both books that's
what he said he said i couldn't because
they sold their rights already so i
couldn't do nothing with it so if you
can't say him be like oh hbo only wants
to do this no
but i like i like what we put together i
like this i mean
i like the ideas we came up with i like
the arguments i like what i learned i
like um
the debates you know what i'm saying
like in the perfect world we would be
able to go home with more of the cops
you know what i'm saying but
also the story of wayne jenkins is a
maybe we need to zero in on that you
know like what's home
but zero in we zero in on wayne and i
think
that is something that we so with sony's
documentary sonya could have did a deep
dive into the gun trace task force she
she she talked to wayne a bunch right
she
she had connections
sonya chose to focus on shawn trudeau
she was dope but imagine how she
wouldn't be able to focus on him and his
family
if she tried to tell this if she tried
to go home
because
i knew
i knew some of gondo's girlfriends that
i was able to plug her with yeah i knew
like
um i had shoot his first wife like i had
i had a collection of people from my own
research and conversations yeah that i
was able to plug her with broadening
right it was all about like you you know
you were like you knew this you knew
this you knew it so you did this you
were like doing that thing and you
excelled in that thing but then like
every step of the way it was about
broadening it was like and then you saw
this and you said they used to the book
then the college they like it was like
just kind of like bro and every time you
broadened
you know you've just gotten wiser and
better and more healthy and found more
peace of mind which are like closer to
your truth that's what it it seems like
to me i think like we have a truth you
got to be connected like if you want to
be happy you got to be true you got to
be authentic if you're not that like
you're oh like faking it you'll always
be miserable that's why like punk asses
who talk too loud can't do [ __ ] it's
like they're miserable that's why
they're talking too loud because that's
not who they are right what the [ __ ] am
i gonna do like just working right as
rooms and make shows and [ __ ] like no
man when i can like go to a park like
what the [ __ ] do i look man i mean first
of all it's like first of all it's like
i mean i'm not against parts and [ __ ]
like i'm perfect well don't you got to
like think about it
like there's some l.a [ __ ] look
look the box
yeah all these [ __ ] i'll be doing
like on a round dude dude you want you
can be [ __ ] outside bro i'm like i
hate to say it i love dc with every bit
of my body dude i'm dc like like i love
dc yo man the east coast is some [ __ ]
trash compared to the west coast ah it's
just [ __ ] trash cause it's trash it's
[ __ ] like like i hate to say it i hate
to say it but like dude it's just when
you go live out there you're like yo i
love that i grew up here but like i
don't need to ever live there again ever
ever ever ever ever
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff it'd mean a lot to us
i hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself